part b
find the slope of the tangent line to
the path of the particle at time t is
equal to 3.
so the slope of the tangent line is just
going to be equal to
the rate of change of y with respect to
x at that point and this is the same
thing as
d y
d t
over
d x d t and dealing with differentials
is a little bit strange especially when
you want to deal with rigorously but you
can view them as very little small
changes in y small changes in t small
changes in x small changes in t when you
view it this way you could say hey look
if i just multiply both sides both the
numerator and the denominator by dt over
dt which if you do view them as the same
small change then they would cancel out
and you would get back to the dy over dx
and the reason why i wrote it this way
is that they actually give us they
actually give us these values they give
us dydt and they give us dx dt so if you
wanted to find the slope if you want to
find the slope at time what do they want
at time equals 3 we just have to find we
just have to find d y d t at time equals
three and d x d t at time equals three
so d y d t at time equals three well
this is d y d t right over here it's
just going to be sine of three squared
or sine of 9
sine of 9 and dx dt at time 3 that's
just going to be they tell us what dx dt
is as a function of time 4 times 3 plus
1 well that's 13.
that is equal to 13. and then we can
just get our calculator out and evaluate
this
and we kind of did a lot of this work in
the first problem but let's just
actually take the value so we have sine
sine of 9 divided by 13.
divided by 13 gets us 0.0317
0.0317
and we're done that's the slope of the
tangent line to the path of the particle
at time t is equal to 3 did i copy that
right yeah three one seven there you go
i think we have time we could crank out
part c as well
part c find the position of the particle
at time t is equal to three
so they give us they give us x prime of
t they give us x prime of t and they
give us y prime of t this is x prime of
t this is y prime of t we need to figure
out we need to figure out x of x of 3
and y of 3. so let's write let's write
what the if we can let's write our
functions let's write x of t and y of t
and then try to evaluate them at 3.
so let's see x of t
x of t is going to be equal to the
antiderivative of this right over here
so the antiderivative of 4t
is going to be 2t squared
take the derivative here you'll just get
4t antiderivative of 1 is t plus t and
then you're going to have a plus a
constant or essentially we just took the
indefinite integral of this side of 4t
plus 1. so you get your constant here
because if you take the derivative this
constant will obviously disappear you
lose that information lucky for us they
also gave us this initial con condition
x of zero is zero so when x is zero
when we're sorry when t is zero this
term is going to be zero this term is
going to be zero so this and they're
saying the whole thing is going to be
equal zero so c is going to be zero as
well let me do that explicitly just so
we don't get confused so x of zero is
going to be equal to zero plus zero plus
c
which they're telling us is equal to
zero so c is equal to zero so that tells
us that x of t
is going to be equal to two t squared
plus t
so if you wanna find
if you wanna find x of three you just
evaluate it right over here
so if you wanna find x of 3 it's going
to be 2 times 9 plus 3 2 times 9 is 18
plus 3 is 21. so x of 3 is 21. now let's
try to do y of t
i'll do it in a different color so let's
let me scroll over to the right a little
bit so let's see y of t is equal to so
if you try to take the anti-derivative
of this this is not a this is not simple
to take the anti-derivative of this
right over here it's actually it's
actually very hard to do it analytically
not even clear if you can do it
analytically lucky for us this part of
the ap exam we are allowed to use
calculators so we could just say this is
equal to and this is straight from the
fundamental theorem of calculus y of t
is equal to the integral from
0 to t and i'll just write it as sine of
x squared
dx and i had to use an x not to i didn't
want to use a t here and then use a t as
well that would make it confusing so you
integrate with respect to x and then one
of the upper bound is going to be t and
this is y of t
and of course you're gonna have to put a
constant over here because if you took
the derivative of this you would get y
of t and you'll lose the information
from this constant and we can figure out
what that constant is because they tell
us what y of zero is
so y of zero is going to be equal to the
integral from zero to zero so this part
right over here is going to be zero so
it's going to be equal to c which they
tell us y of zero is also equal to
negative four
so we get y of t is equal to the
integral from 0 to t
of sine of x squared dx
minus 4. so that's y as a function of t
and they want us to figure out what we
already figured out what x of 3 is now
we have to figure out what y of 3 is
y of 3 is going to be equal to the
integral from 0 to 3 of sine
of x squared dx and then minus 4. and
once again lucky for us we can use
calculators here
so let's get the calculator out and we
want to use we want to go to our
the catalog of functions i press second
custom here which gives us this little
catalog thing and i want to do the
definite integral and that's it's
actually fn int so let me go to the f's
so let me go to the f's
f and int so i have to go a little bit
further down
a little bit there you go that's my
function that i want to use this is a
definite integral and then i want to
evaluate the definite integral of this
right over here so the function is going
to be sine
of
sine of x squared
that's what i want to evaluate the
definite integral of
from
from
0 to 3 from 0 to 3 and my variable sorry
i need to say what the variable of
integration is first so my variable of
integration is x and i'm going to go
from 0
to 3.
and this gives me
this
gives me
let's see let the calculator think a
little bit
0.77356
and then to that so that's just this
first part right over here and then i
need to subtract 4. so minus 4
minus 4 gives negative
3.226 i'll go with so this is equal to
negative
3.226 did i write that down right i have
a bad memory negative 3.226
and we're done so y of 3 is equal to
negative 3.226
so the position of the particle at time
t equals 3 if you wanted a coordinate
if you wanted a coordinate it would be
21 comma negative 3.226